foreign
ER Smith today an opportunity to touch
base quickly uh before the health
discussions we're going to have this
afternoon obviously that's a big
priority for Canadians we're going to be
focused on delivering results for them
and do in a way that is responsive to
the varying realities across the
province from across the country
um I'm sure we'll also talk about
albertans and how we can make sure we're
supporting them how certain
energy workers and workers in general
have been extraordinarily important to
the success of Canada over many many
decades and we need to make sure they
continue to be strong into the future as
well
the world needs our know-how Alberta
energy and solutions for the coming
years and I'm looking forward to
continuing to work with the governor of
Alberta on delivering for people thank
you uh
comments for all the English I'm
delighted to be able to have an
opportunity to talk about some areas of
common interest and maybe some areas of
diversions and see if we can find some
common interests we have I think a lot
of shared goals in addressing issues of
indigenous Health Care Mental Health
addition home care community-based care
as we transform our Health Care system
so I'm pleased that we'll
all of the help all the other premiers
today
but of course I did write a letter to
the Prime Minister a couple of weeks ago
expressing concern about some of the
major initiatives that have been
announced without much consultation with
Alberta that has stand to have a huge
impact on our Province uh the just
transition legislation that gives the
impression that the energy sector is
going to be phased out it's not going
phased out we're transforming away from
high intensity emissions to lower
emissions and I think we could have some
shared priorities on that on LNG export
to reduce emissions using
the green transfer mechanism to get
credit here that would also help British
Columbia working on critical minerals
hydrogen geothermal lithium I think that
there's a lot of opportunity for us to
find some
also concerned about the
green electricity regulations our
province has 90 of our electricity grid
on natural gas
and so an early phase out of natural gas
is just simply
exults in a reliable or affordable
option for our province
also a proposed emissions cap on the
energy sector we've said very clearly
that a an aggressive emissions cap such
as was initially proposed would really
be a production cap
because there isn't a feasible way for
us to achieve that within eight years so
with any luck we'll find some common
ground on some of those issues today
because I think it's going to be
important for all of Alberta of role of
Canada
they we do find Common Grounds so that
we can continue to move forward on
addressing positions together
got some cookies